mr speaker i don't think the prime
minister understands the messi's in
working families are facing a 700 pound
spike in april
they won't even receive their 200 pound
loan from the chancellor until october
the wholesale price of oil and gas is
now ballooning so by october when the
loan finally comes in household bills
are set to shoot up by another a
thousand pounds
it's a total mess
so i ask again when is the prime
minister going to force the chancellor
to u-turn
prime minister
mr speaker he's asking for the
chancellor to u-turn on the support that
we're giving to families and households
i i think that i think that he's uh i
think that he's absolutely out of his
mind uh we are
we're we are going to we are going to
continue uh to give people support
throughout this difficult period as we
did throughout the coronavirus epidemic
mr speaker with unprecedented levels of
of support we have a 200-pound discount
on bills 150 pound a non-repayable a
reduction in a council tax and 144
million pounds extra to help council
support vulnerable families uh with
their energy bills uh
all together mr speaker there is a 20
billion pound package of financial help
that we are giving the british people
and we will continue to do more i think
a u-turn is as big as the last thing we
want
[Applause]
mr speaker we'll see how long that
position lasts
uh let me try and
let me try and help the prime minister
let me try and help the prime minister
by coming at it from a different angle
before russia invaded ukraine north sea
oil and gas companies were making bumper
profits
bp made 9.5 billion pounds
shell made 14 billion pounds in their
own words more money than they know what
to do with
since then the international price of
oil and gas has skyrocketed and so will
their profits
when will the prime minister admit he's
got this badly wrong put a windfall tax
on those super profits and use the money
to cut household energy bills
[Applause]
mr speaker the the net result of that
would simply be to see the oil companies
uh put their prices up yet higher
mr speaker uh what we are what we are
and and and mr speaker uh and mr speaker
make it more difficult for them to do
what we need them to do and which i
think by the way mr speaker they are
doing very responsibly at the moment and
that is divesting from dependence on
russian oil and gas and that is the that
is the way forward for this country it
is to take it is to take a sober
responsible approach uh end our
dependence on on on hydrocarbons
altogether and particularly russian
hydrocarbons and we are taking steps to
rectify some of the mistakes made by the
labor government and have a long-term
sustainable independent energy supply
policy that's what this country needs
[Music]
[Applause]
protecting energy profits not working
people doesn't that say it all
written
britain can't
britain can't afford another crisis like
this we need to improve our long-term
energy security that starts that starts
with supporting new nuclear and
renewables but the conservatives have
effectively banned new onshore wind
as a direct result of this short-sighted
approach we're using more gas every year
than we import from russia
that's ludicrous
so will the prime minister relax
planning laws end the block on onshore
wind and stop supporting policies that
make us so dependent on foreign gas